the Quran says the Quran says that the
disciples were spreading the message of
Jesus and that Allah helped them spread
the message of Jesus against
disbelievers and he says that he made
the followers of Jesus Victorious over
the disbelievers and he says that he
will make them Victorious they will
remain Victorious until the day of
judgment so there's no point in time
where the disbelievers will overcome the
Believers of Jesus and be able to
corrupt their message because Allah
promised to preserve them against them
to hold them higher and Victorious over
the disbelievers so there's no way they
can come in and corrupt the message of
the followers logic how you doing good
how are you I'm good I'm good so I just
want to ask you a question like just
something off topic before I go through
the question independent something off
topic before I go to the question of the
independ right what what makes you think
it's okay to come here and go off the
topic that I have on the panel and put
my topic that I have on the panel on the
side and say we'll get to that later
well okay I can go through the topic
that you want but all right sure I we go
through the topic then I'm going to ask
you the question all right fair enough
all right so all right so explain to me
your question because I don't understand
it it's not really a question it's just
a statement it's an observation I made
by reading the Quran that Allah made me
believe in the crucifixion well how
though well he made it he made it appear
that Jesus was on the cross but when he
really wasn't right okay so first of all
bring the verse second of all I think I
know the verse but it doesn't say that
Allah made appear so it just it appeared
so okay you're right it doesn't
explicitly say that Allah made it appear
so it just says but it was made to
appear so it was made to appear so my
question is this and the verse is
chapter 4 verse 157 all up my question
would be this who made it appear so that
Jesus was crucified who made it like he
was crucified who made it seem like he
was crucified that that tricked all
those thousands of people so like are
you asking like did Allah predetermine
it because there's a difference between
predetermination and predestination
exactly I'm not asking about well no but
I'm not asking about determination I'm
asking about who did it who made it
appear that Jesus was crucified on the
cross well it's probably the the people
who pers who persecuted Jesus wait
wouldn't the people who persecuted Jesus
want him to be crucified why would they
trick people to make them think he was
crucified wouldn't they want to crucify
him actually what do you mean like okay
what do you mean by chistian can you
reate your question again you said maybe
it was the people who was persecuting
Jesus that made it appear that he was
crucified right yeah my question is
wouldn't they want to crucify Jesus in
reality like they wouldn't want to fake
it they would actually want to kill him
right but but what the point is Allah
actually is switch Jesus with someone
else because they W crucified who's who
switched Jesus with somebody else Allah
so it was Allah who made it appear that
Jesus was crucified but he didn't but
but he didn't give the choice you know
he didn't predetermine it but he's the
one their free will to try to do it he's
the one who he's the one exactly he's
the one who performed the substitution
that tricked everybody right not trick I
wanton say trick well well okay was
Jesus really crucified I see no and and
people thought that he really was
crucified right because they they
thought they were crucifying Jesus right
I mean I don't see any evidence from you
know your your Bible that suggest so
it's not about my Bible it's about your
Quran I know I know but if so your Quran
says that the people thought that they
crucified Jesus right yeah and the
reason why they thought that is because
Allah tricked them into believing that
right not tricked I want say tricked
well that's what a trick is is when you
get someone to think Jes not no trick
implies where he promised something and
then he doesn't doesn't do Allah didn't
promise for Jesus to get crucified
that's not that's not what a trick is a
trick is when you mislead someone into
believing something that what that's not
true wait is all right so okay okay so
what's your point what's your point so
Allah is the one is the reason why
people believed Jesus was crucified in
the first place right I mean I mean I
have no argument so I can't make a
conclusion right now but not it's not
about it's not about you having to have
an argument just follow the logic where
it leads Allah is the one who
substituted Jesus on the cross there
there thereby making people believe that
they're crucifying Jesus when they're
actually not so this idea this belief
that Jesus was crucified was started by
Allah's trick he made us believe that he
was crucified that he was really on the
cross when he wasn't right
I mean I mean I don't know yet but sure
sure let's just go with that let's go
for the S sure all right so when that's
the case Allah tricked all of us into
believing a false thing which then
birthed Christianity I want say I want
to say about Christianity because
Christianity all right wait the
Christianity doesn't only depend on the
crucifixion it depends on many other
things the Christianity the Crux of it
begins at the crucifixion of Jesus and
his resurrection him being him rising
from the dead these people seeing Jesus
alive and saying hold on a second we we
we saw you get crucified and and Jesus
is like well I'm alive here I am look
I'm alive they swear up and down that
they that Jesus then rose from the dead
because they saw or they think that they
saw Jesus actually die because of Allah
I mean I mean I saw it like okay so
we're not talking about Christianity so
of course we're going to bring up you
know the biblical thought of crucifixion
right we're going to bring up you know
if we're talk about Christianity of
course we're going to talk about how you
know the Bible talks about Jesus not
being crucified it doesn't say exactly
where he was where he was crucified each
four gospels doesn't say anything about
him being crucified so let's see John
chapter 19 all right John this yeah yeah
John chapter 19 wait what which which
translation doesn't matter pick anyone
I'm going start at verse Right Use the
ACV right I use the ESV yeah all right
I'm going to bring up the John chapter
19 starting at verse 16 it says wait let
me bring let me bring up let me bring it
up so first all right let me let me know
when you're ready man all right okay
brought it all right starting in verse
16 so he delivered him over to them to
be crucified so they took Jesus and went
out bearing and he and he went out
bearing his own cross to the place
called the place of of a skull which is
which in Aramaic is called gatha there
they crucified him and with him two
others on one on one on either side and
Jesus between them pilate also wrote on
the inscription and put it on the cross
it read Jesus of Nazareth the king of
the Jews so according to the Gospel of
Jesus on the account of John Jesus was
clearly crucified right which wait if
you go to the part again which part
Verse 18 bro all right Verse 18 why are
you clicking I thought you were already
there yeah no no I'm just highlighting
highlight you see the verse yeah I see
so so according to the gospel the
account of John Jesus was clearly
crucified right well yeah wait so you're
saying that's according to John right
that's according to God John's gospel
Jesus was crucified right as we just
read I mean right for now sure until I
do my research until I do my research
sure I mean this is the research you got
you're you're reading it from the
horse's mouth you're in John it's right
in your face you got it on your screen
it says in verse 18 I'll let you read it
can you read it out loud what verse 18
says okay sure all right so it says
There They Crucified him with two others
one on either side and Jesus between
them all right so according to this
Jesus was definitely crucified along
with two other people right yeah yeah
all right beautiful let's go over to
Luke now go to Luke wait before we go to
Luke like is okay is it okay we just you
know look at John 19:17 nope oh yeah
okay you said none of the gospels say
that Jesus was crucified that's what you
said so I'm showing you that all of the
gospels say that he was crucified well
I'll do my research all but just bring
the I'm helping you do your research
right now man that's what I'm here for
you're doing your research right now so
I know but but the research doesn't end
with you it it ends when I do my when I
do the conclusion when I look at I'm
starting you off I'm just giving you a
head start now so you go to can you go
to Luke 23 now okay Luke 23 sure all
right so you're going to read verse 33
and 34 wait John 23 Luke 23
oh Luke 23 read 33 and 34 you there yeah
okay okay so well you know I'm not
really that knowledgeable on the
crucifixion so for for now you know I'm
going to do my research so just you know
give me a head story then I'm going to
do my research that's what I'm doing are
you there at the verse yeah okay so okay
so where Matthew and the other does it
say wait did you did you read Luke yeah
I read okay I'm going read it out loud
for the people Luke 23 verse 33 and 34
and when they came to the place that is
called the skull There They Crucified
him and the criminals one on his right
and one on his left and Jesus said said
father forgive them for they know not
what they do and they cast lots to
divide his garments all right now here
Mark go to Mark chapter 14 I'm sorry
Mark 15 excuse me Mark 16 or Mark 15
verse 22 okay all right all right so
that's okay is it okay if we just you
know go through Mark then I'm going to
ask him a question oh we're still on
this topic yeah until you finish the
topic yeah so you have Mark 15 you're
going to read verse 24 Mark 15: 24 and
they crucified him and divided his
garments among them casting lots for
them to decide what each should take
Mark 15:
[Music]
24 Matthew you're up Matthew Matthew all
right Matthew Matthew 27 verse 35
Matthew 27 verse 35
it says and when they had crucified him
they they divided his garments among
them by casting lots so the all four
gospels are consistent that Jesus was
crucified and that the soldiers gambled
over his clothing When They Crucified
him which is a fulfilled prophecy in
Psalm 22 well I'm going have to look
that up sure but for now I tell you know
I'm not that knowledgeable on the on the
you know crucifixtion so I don't have
any common on all right so to go to my
off topic question well let me let me
conclude my point and then we can go off
so I want you to understand why this is
important so obviously you have the
gospels that teach that Jesus was
crucified but then you have here the
Quran saying oh well no it was made to
appear so and that Allah substituted
somebody the crown doesn't say this but
this is y'all's understanding Allah
substituted somebody in the place of
Jesus making everyone think that Jesus
was being crucified so Allah is the one
who tricked everyone into to believing
in the crucifixion of Jesus thus
starting Christianity wait so you're
saying that Allah started Christianity
yes Allah is the one who started
Christianity Habibi bro Allah doesn't
condemn you for that you know why Allah
condemns you in the first place that's
not the only reason why he condemns you
I mean sure he he tells that it didn't
happen but he doesn't doesn't condemn
you for that reason only he condemns you
for making him a Divine person making
you know believing in a trinity and a
lot of other stuff that doesn't make
sense up God being a human damn CL
contradiction well none of this stuff
would have happened if he would have
just if he not tricked us into believing
that Jesus died by crucifixion and then
rose again on the third day when his
when his disciples saw him alive again
and then started proclaiming him to be
Lord of Heaven and Earth because he rose
himself up from the dead that's what
they believe not really because black
people exist do you believe that bad
people exist huh bad people exist so now
do you believe that bad people exist
what does that have to do with what I
said let me tell you why because black
people were corrupt was the original
message to make it seem as he you know
as this as he was this person who yeah
you you want to know you want to know
how that also is a self-refuting
argument what do you mean just make AR
the reason why what you just said is is
absolutely detrimental to you as a
Muslim is because the Quran says that
the Disciples of Jesus Will remain
Victorious over the bad people Quran
says that the bad people will never be
able to overcome can you bring the verse
first yeah it's chapter 61 yeah verse 14
okay so now first of all you're going to
have to you know to prove that you got
the things that you know the books that
you guys have came from the original
disciples I don't have to Pro that your
Quran already says it so which which
verse well let's focus on one at a time
first we're going to focus on how your
Quran says that when the disciples are
helping Jesus spread this message that
they will not be defeated by the bad
people that they will overcome the bad
people and always overcome the bad
people the bad people will never be able
to get in and overcome the the followers
of Jesus never so logic are you saying
that they are so they like you know so
like there will be Victorious on this
Earth or like on the day on this Earth
the Quran says here this Earth where
like I don't see it chapter 61 verse 14
wait let me just all believer stand up
as no no read it out loud so we can all
hear there's no need for me to do that
but sure stand up for Allah as Jesus Son
of Mary asked the disciples who will
stand up with me for Allah the disciples
rep we will stand up for Allah then a
group from Children of Israel believed
While others disbelieved we then
supported the Believers against the
enemies so they were pred beautiful so
you see how it says Jesus told his
disciples to help him in standing up for
Allah right for sure sure what does it
mean to to help in the cause of Allah or
stand up for Allah what does that mean
exactly just probably to spread the
message or like exactly you're
absolutely right you're absolutely right
to spread the message so Jesus was
spreading the message in standing up for
Allah and he asked the disciples to help
him in standing up for Allah which is
spreading the message so the disciples
were also spreading the message right
that Jesus gave them to spread
that Allah gave him to Sprint and it
says that the Disciples of Jesus were
victorious over the bad people right
doesn't say in this earth and they were
victories in this Earth so where where
were they where were they standing up
where were they standing up for Allah in
Heaven no on Earth very good so but that
doesn't mean Victorious going happen in
this earth it might happen in the next
life come on brother don't don't don't
don't play these games man don't play
these games that's basic that's basic
quranic literature bro that's not
there's not even a there's no single
scholar that even understands it that
way so please stop all right they're on
Earth they're spreading the message on
Earth so are they going to be successful
in spreading the message or will they be
unsuccessful in spreading the message
successful but that doesn't mean that
the message would stay until the day of
judgment the message okay nice it
doesn't mean that the message will stay
preserved until the day of judgment go
to chapter 3 chapter 3 55 this verse
seals the deal we all saw it coming okay
so what's okay so okay so you're saying
because he say Elevate okay
makees just read the verse and then
you'll see what the argument is read the
verse out loud please so we can all be
with you okay but after I read is it
okay if you make your argument that's
what I just said okay sure remember
remember I said oh Jesus I'll take you
and raise you up to myself I'll deliver
you from those who disbelieved and
elevate your followers above the
disbeliever until the day of judgment
then to me you all return now serve all
disputes so what's wrong with this verse
so you see how it says that the
Disciples of Jesus not just them but all
the followers of Jesus will be
victorious until the day of judgment
right but victorious in what in spre in
helping the cause of Allah in what we
just read in 6114 wello you know you
know what you do you just take some
verses and then you you know you put
them together that's not how it works
you need to read each verse in context
before you
what what was the okay in 61 ver14 the
one we PRI read prior what were the
disciples doing that Allah made them
victorious in over the disbelievers you
know trying to spread the message good
so Allah May helped them in spreading
the message and therefore made them
Victorious over the disbelievers in
spreading the message over here in 355
it continues the same thought and says
that the Believers of Jesus will be
victorious over the disbelievers right
yeah what's the difference there there
is no difference so it's talking about
the same thing the only thing that's the
only thing that's different is that it
gives you more detail it says how long
they'll be victorious which is until the
day of judgment but victorious in terms
that they he will Elevate them and that
even the verse that says this it says
that uppermost above the disbelievers
how would they be uppermost above the
disbelievers inde deed in ranks no no
not has nothing what what deed ranks
what deed what deed Good Deeds what Good
Deed of them spreading the message boom
so them spreading the message is the
good deed that elevates them and puts
them above the disbelievers so they're
Victorious above the disbelievers in
spreading the message until the day of
judgment so there's not any point in
time where the disbelievers the bad
people will be elevated or Victorious
over the followers of Jesus they can't
get in and corrupt the message of the
followers of Jesus because they have
Allah's help but that doesn't that Allah
you know Allah preserved it that L if he
didn't then he's a liar that's not okay
so make AR because like my alarm hit so
what I'll make it I'll make it I'll make
it very simple the Quran says the Quran
says that the disciples were spreading
the message of Jesus and that Allah
helped them spread the message of Jesus
against disbelievers and he says that he
made the followers of Jesus Victorious
over the disbelievers and and he says
that he will make them Victorious they
will remain Victorious until the day of
judgment so there's no point in time
where the disbelievers will overcome the
Believers of Jesus and be able to
corrupt their message because Allah
promise to preserve them against them to
hold them higher and Victorious over the
disbelievers so there's no way they can
come in and corrupt the message of the
followers of Jesus they can't do it you
know what you just did you just jumped
over the point you you builded your
argument but then you jumped to the
conclusion without making another
argument what you did here is that you
you tried to say just because oh look
just because they are they are you know
Victorious over the disbelievers that
means that they are that they that the
message is still preserved but that's
not what the verbs say you're trying to
make conclusion based on false false
premises okay I think that I think
that's the that's it now you know okay
I'm I'm go over my question we don't we
don't have I I like like intellectually
you know you know we reached we reached
the limit okay well whatever okay when
when you can't when you can't even
accept what your Quran says and then you
have to make stuff up with what your
Quran says um you know I'm not making up
what can we do how can I have a
conversation with you okay now can I go
to my my question does your Quran say
that they'll be victorious until the day
of judgment wait didn't you just end the
conversation thanks for coming bro wait
wait I'll just go over my off topic
question first before you
go okay so would you to dishonest for me
waste of time